[Music]
this is lauren from our studio please
warm welcome
[Applause]
thank you thank you greg good afternoon
everyone my name is lauren chadwick i
work on
r studios customer success team i really
didn't want to kick off today with a
typical
this is my title and this is what it
means type of introduction
but it turns out as it relates to the
broader topic and what i want to share
with you today
my role in customer success is one of
the more relevant factors
now to this day i've supported over 200
organizations
primarily companies in the life sciences
umbrella as well as a lot of our
university accounts
and in that journey i've gotten to
really dig in and figure out what these
people are doing with r
what problems they're solving what
challenges they're facing
what their architecture and their
environment looks like and what their
forward-looking plans are for the
language
all of the good stuff right i get that
high-level view over all of these teams
that i work with
and it's my absolute passion to dig in
and figure out how we can best support
them
and how we can make their lives a little
bit easier and that's what it
regardless of where you are on your
journey with r today
and regardless of what you know what
your story is i can't get that full
picture for you today i can't figure out
what the most interesting thing to you
is in the first 20 minutes that i have
here
but what i can say is that you're an
asset to our community you're somebody
that our studio is thinking a lot about
and really wants to help
and probably can help and that's what i
want to talk to you about today
i've titled my talk meet you where you
are in hopes to shed some light on the
ways that our studio can be leveraged at
various points in a data science journey
and how the teams and the universities
that i'm working with are already doing
that today
now in the eyes of our studio there's
really three key areas that we're hyper
focused on to ensure that the open
source community
that this right here lives on for a
really long time
the first one is approachability how to
make the r language approachable
how to make it easy to learn and easy to
use are
the second one is communicating in
production
how do you bridge the gap between the r
user and the data scientists working in
r every day
and the stakeholder of the work that
they're doing
the third one is leveraging other tools
how do you extend the r
language the r studio software to work
well with other tools
and languages and technologies that are
valued by all of you and by the
community
and as you'll see as we go along each of
these three buckets kind of naturally
maps to different points of a data
science journey that a team might go
through
now when you think about approachability
making the r language approachable easy
to learn
easy to use a few things from our studio
that you might think about are things
like the tidy verse
or the cheat sheets that we all love or
the webinars that our studio frequently
holds to deep dive into certain topics
or perhaps one of our later investments
are studiocloud
now can i get a show of hands here for
anybody that knows what rstudio cloud is
or anybody that's used it
great a lot of you well for those of you
who don't know our studio cloud is a
free r studio hosted platform designed
for the purpose of teaching and learning
in fact if you go to rstudio.cloud right
now and you scroll down half an inch
you'll see that our mission is to
literally make it easy to share
teach and learn data science using r
and the reason rstudio cloud makes that
so easy is because you don't have to
download or install anything to be able
to use it
right all you need is an email address
and once you've taken those few minutes
you've created an account with our
studio cloud you log in here
you'll see like i'm showing on my screen
that you have the rstudio ide
at your disposal right without having to
install anything
so rather than your first experience
with r being all about trying to
download and get everything working on
your desktop
you get to focus that time and energy on
getting excited about learning r
getting excited about learning the ide
right once you're out here you have all
of these different tools at your
disposal
to help make it even easier for example
you have
these primers which are essentially
interactive tutorials designed to help
you learn the basics of the language
you have your user guide you have your
cheat sheets
right without even having to leave the r
studio cloud platform you have this
wealth of resources at your fingertips
to help make it easy
and in conversations that i have with
teams i see this being used at all sorts
of levels here
for example at the individual level
i work with a lot of it and admin
resources that don't necessarily need to
know r for their day-to-day work
but they want to better understand what
they're bringing into their university
or their organization
just want to understand it a little bit
better at the academic level
our studio is supporting over 650
universities
that are using our studio cloud to teach
data science in the classroom today
over 650 universities that number is
constantly growing
on the corporate side of the world my
customer success team sees this you
being used pretty extensively as well in
my personal experience i work with a lot
of companies
that are undergoing some form of a sas
to r migration
and need to completely learn the r
language from scratch
we also see companies and universities
that have their own internal r meetup
groups
or their own conferences or our day or
shiny day
and to encourage participation in those
sessions and encourage people to come
and get their hands on r
they're using our studio cloud for that
in fact a great corporate example of a
team that's using our studio cloud
pretty extensively is johnson johnson
last month on december 4th johnson and
johnson did a public facing webinar
where they dove into their use case for
rstudio cloud
and why they chose to use it and what
they're using it for for corporate
trainings
and the reason they chose to use it as
you can see here is because of
simplicity
it's easy to use and that's our whole
goal with approachability is to make
r easy to learn easy to use
but maybe you're at a point in your
journey where you don't need to learn r
you already know it
you're using it every day you're working
in r you're making reports you're making
shiny applications dashboards
what have you so how do we help you
that brings us to our next area of
investment which is communicating in
production
how do you bridge that gap between the
our users and teams
working in our everyday and the
stakeholders of the work that they're
doing
right and we know that as a data
scientist that's working in r every day
that your very first thought when you
built
our markdown report or a dashboard or a
great shiny application that your very
first thought is not going to be
how do i get this to everyone else right
your first thought is going to be all
the steps that it takes to make it
interactive and make it look nice and
make it work
but at the end of the day unless maybe
you're a hobbyist you're not about to
make that dashboard
or that markdown report or that
application for no reason
you're doing it because somebody out
there whether it's your
your students your university your
research team your customers
your clients somebody out there wants to
interact with the work that you're doing
to make a decision or to answer a
question to gain more insights
right and if you're anything like the
teams i'm working with
you might already have ways of doing
that today maybe you have a git
repository for all your work
or maybe you're copying and pasting your
code and your plots into powerpoint
slides before your meetings
maybe if it comes to an r markdown
report or a notebook
you're emailing them around as
attachments
right so all of your work is all over
the place that's okay
that could work for some time but what
happens when you build more and more
data products
and more types of data products and more
and more people become interested in the
work that you're doing and want to be
able to see it
and what happens when every single
person on your team is doing the exact
same thing as you are
and suddenly everyone's work is
throughout different inboxes different
emails different folders
different get repositories different
powerpoint slides
that's a mess right that's inarguably
messy
it's manual it's time-consuming and
you're setting yourself up to lose sight
of work that you spent a lot of time and
energy on
and that's a mess that my team in
customer success saw day in and day out
when meeting with different universities
in different companies
and that's the mess that we engineered
our studio connect to help fix
now rstudio connect is a publishing
platform it's a central location for all
the work that you're doing in r
and all the work that you're doing in
python and it's intended to be installed
behind your university
or your company's firewall so our studio
doesn't have access to any of your data
or any of the data products that you're
putting on our studio connect
and to show you an example i'm going to
flip back over here to the r studio ide
the one that i'm showing here right now
is our studio server pro
this is our professional browser-based
ide but you can use any ide that you
want the free desktop the free server
whatever your preference is as you can
see here i'm about to show you an
application that i put a ton of blood
and sweat and tears into
you ready
here it is old faithful hello world my
application
right and as you can see in this moment
this application
can only be consumed by me right it's
running in my laptop on my personal
session
nobody else can interact with it unless
i pass my laptop around the room
as great of an option as it would be to
pass my laptop around the room to all of
you
you'll also notice that i have this
little blue button here in the top right
hand corner
it's a publishing button when i click
that button what it allows me to do is
send my application
or my report or whatever i've built here
to our studio connect
so you can see now that i'm on our
studio connect i have the same
application
but now it's in a position where other
people can interact with it
and the cool thing about connect is i as
the data scientist the publisher
of this amazing application i get to
control who exactly
i want to be able to interact with it
whether it's just a few people
on my team or my entire research group
or my
entire company my entire customer base
right i get to control that
and once you're out here there's all
sorts of different bells and whistles
designed for the different use cases
that you might have for a publishing
platform like this
whether it be an internal collaboration
use case amongst your university
or whether you're a company trying to
deploy an application to hundreds of
customers
right we see it all connect was
engineered with all of those different
use cases in mind
and i don't have the time to go through
each and every one of them today but
what i can show you is a few of
our fan favorites here for example if i
wanted to share my application with a
group of people
on my team but i didn't want them to
have to log into rcdo connect
what i can do is assign a custom vanity
url to the application
and share that with them so if i share
that this url down here
and they click it they can open the same
application in a web browser here
and interact with it without seeing all
the background of our studio connect
a lot of teams that i work with have a
use case for our markdown as well
so if you have an r markdown report you
want it to automatically run
every monday at 8 am you can do that
with rcdo connect and set it to run
automatically on a recurring basis and
then from there you get to decide
whether or not you want an email to go
out
to a group of people based on certain
parameters that are important to you
now every morning monday to friday i
wake up and i have two refreshed our
markdown reports in my inbox ready to be
searched
and that's awesome right nobody had to
touch that to make that happen
all right so rco connect is really
designed to help organize your content
in a way that makes sense for your use
case
and man automate processes that are
manual in nature
but maybe one of the biggest advantages
of our studio connect is it's not only
designed for the work that you're doing
in r
it's also designed for the work that
you're doing in python
so for example if you have a different
part of your university
or different part of your company that's
using jupiter notebooks or maybe you've
made a reticulated asset that uses both
r and python under the hood with that
same deployment process you can also
send that to rstudioconnect
and to give you a glimpse a lot of teams
that we're working with a lot of the
university
that we're working with have already
found this successful in their workflows
in fact in the last month i've worked
with two completely different
universities
and their corresponding med schools to
help implement a company-wide
university-wide
instance of our studio connect for all
other teams our products and all other
teams python data products
and that takes me nicely to the third
and final investment area that i want to
share with you today which is leveraging
other tools
now to nobody's surprise r is very
special to us
if i had to guess i'd guess that it also
hold some degree of importance to all of
you as well
and if not you might be in the wrong
hotel this week
but we can also come to terms with the
idea that once you're using
r and rstudio and your workflows and
once you bring them to production
that there's also going to be a lot of
other tools and languages and
technologies that are important to you
right for example maybe you're using
docker or you're using spark you're
trying to connect to databases
you're using get or tensorflow right so
how do we as a company
extend the r language and the r studio
software to work nicely with all of
those other types of tools
and for the sake of relevancy to the
last example let's take a deeper look
into python
how a lot of universities and a lot of
companies have a use case for both r
and python both languages are incredibly
powerful
they're used for different purposes
they're solving different problems
and we work with a lot of teams that
have a use case for both
so how do we help support those teams
how do we help make it so you can use r
and python in the same exact workflow
or at least have them co-exist nicely
under the same roof
now we already talked about how with
rstudio connect you can share the python
work that you're doing
but what if we take a step back and look
at the development side the admin side
what about the it and the admin
resources that are responsible for
overseeing two completely different
environments
or what about the multilingual user
that's constantly flipping between
development environments just to get
their work done
how do we support those people to answer
that question
a few months ago back in september our
studio introduced
jupiter support in rstudio server pro
which is a professional browser-based
ide
where i showed you that hideous
application before
and now universities and companies that
have any mix of a use case for both
r and python have one development
environment to log into to get their
work done
in just one environment to manage their
workflows
flip back over here i'm going to show
you our studio server pro
as you can see here this time i'm on the
home screen
if i click this new session button
you'll see that i have an editor option
where i can choose from rstudio jupiter
lab or jupiter notebooks
now let's say this time around i'm just
a python user
i don't care about r i don't want to use
it i just want to start a jupiter
notebook
so i'm going to select jupiter notebook
if i click start session
you'll see that i have my jupiter
notebook running inside of our studio
server pro
so as a python user i don't even have to
know that other
r users or python users are running r
studio sessions or jupiter lab sessions
on the same server as me
right all i care about is my jupyter
notebook if the time comes where i'm
ready to share this with other people
you'll see that i have the same blue
publishing button where i can share it
out to our studio connect
so we've come full circle let's say for
a second i'm a multi-lingual
user using both r and python
just as easily can flip back go to our
studio the home screen
and start another our studio session
like i did before
and a lot of you may know that within
rstudio itself you can also do things
like
run python scripts or add python code
chunks to your
markdown reports or use packages like
reticulate to embed
python code into your r section right
there's all sorts of ways that you can
leverage
both languages in your workflows
and as new as a lot of this
functionality is we've already seen it
as a pretty popular option amongst the
teams that we're working with
now a lot of teams that we're working
with
for example i was just in seattle a few
days ago
and i was meeting with a company and
they're looking to replace their jupiter
hub solution with this solution because
they see it as an opportunity to really
reduce their footprint
because they know it's fully supported
by our studio so they know if anything
goes wrong with their r environment
or their python environment they have a
team of people they can reach out to for
help
now i hope to at least have painted a
high level picture of the ways that our
studio is thinking about different
individuals
and data science teams at various parts
of a data science journey
so whether you relate to any of these
specific examples or feel like you fall
somewhere in between
to know that our studio is thinking
about you we want to help you
we want you to live this value live
and because at the end of the day those
universities and companies investing in
the work that we're doing
are the sole reason that we're able to
invest back so heavily in the open
source
and the reason we're able to codify it
in our mission like jj said earlier
and we hope to be able to do this for a
really long time because we really want
to support the open source community
now after everything i wanted to share
with you today imagined i wouldn't have
a ton of time for questions but i do
want to let you know that the r studio
team
will be out in the lounge over the next
few days hoping you guys come and talk
to them
whether it be about this or about
anything else that you're wondering what
people are doing
i also wanted to share some resources
and contact information
in case you have questions or want to
explore any of this at your leisure
feel free to take a picture of this or
write down a new thing
thank you
[Applause]
we have time for one question i'm sorry
we were a little bit late starting and
apologize for that
but lauren's going to be around for the
next couple of days
please come and pick her brains and
please
another warm round of applause for
lauren thank you very much thank you